Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, bah, bah, bah, bah.
Wait...
Where I put...
Where I put my face...
I have a cup...
Cover...
Hold on, let me take a picture.
Wait, oh no, it doesn't show up.
It's like all just...
Hold on.
Wait, it looks better on my...
I have a cup on my desk and it's...
It's clear, right?
And it's like where I have...
Like where I can see my camera, like my face.
And so it's like distorting my face.
It looks like... Oh my gosh, do you remember?
Like the filters that used to be on like Mac computers and stuff like that?
It looks like one of those.
Logan, thanks for the 5 gifted!
I just noticed it.
Just now.
I took a picture, but...
It doesn't... It doesn't show what I see.
Hold on, I'm gonna try another picture.
It doesn't... It doesn't...
It doesn't convey very well.
That's okay though, maybe I'll post it on Twitter later.
You laugh at my face too?
I'm sure you do.
No, I'm just kidding.
Ohamito.
Ohamito!
Anyway.
Hello everybody.
Welcome back to Devil May Cry.
I can't stop looking at it.
Yeah, part 5.
Oh man.
This is the part where I say give birth.
Thank you guys for 9 months!
Or kidai, thanks for 2 months!
Thank you guys.
I delivered a baby!
It's a girl!
Wow.
Congratulations.
Alessio, welcome to Mambo Show.
Thank you.
It's me, Dante from Devil May Cry series.
Wow.
Hold on, sorry.
All the laughing.
For those who don't know, I've been sick.
For like 3... 2 weeks.
2 weeks now.
I hope you fully recovered from illness.
Thank you!
I think I'm like 90% there.
I think maybe.
I think maybe just like a little bit.
Like maybe 2 more days or so.
Actually, I forgot to take my medicine today.
Oopsie!
But it's almost been 3 weeks since I've been sick.
But now I'm getting there.
I'm getting better.
I just have a little bit of a cough.
And...
Take your meds.
I will!
I will, but my...
Thank you!
Hi Minto.
Hi Minto's new PC.
Hi Tummy Horde, please.
Yeah, I was just about to say.
The medicine has made it so that...
When I eat, like...
You know, when someone gives me an offering...
And I eat it...
My tummy hordes so bad!
And it still hurts.
I took an extra couple of minutes to maybe hope that it goes down.
And it didn't!
It's just like a consistent...
It's not like a sharp pain.
It's just like a consistent pain.
And just...
Horde!
So bad!
It kind of makes me a little bit winded.
So...
So if I sound like out of breath...
I apologize.
No, it's not like a cramp.
It's like...
I don't know.
Just anytime I eat.
So I eat breakfast.
And then Tummy Horde.
And then I eat lunch.
And then I eat dinner.
And it's Tummy Horde.
It's just never ending Tummy Horde hours!
It sucks!
But I think it's because of the medicine.
So...
I think maybe once I'm off of it for a bit, it'll help.
Hopefully!
Heartburn?
No.
It's in my tummy.
I don't think I have a heart.
Oh my gosh.
I was just catching up on your last DMC stream.
I'm going to assume you beat Beowulf in a timely manner.
Yeah, I did.
Sick at video games.
I'm sick at everything.
Thank you for 9 months!
Wait.
Thank you for 9 months.
You gotta take your blue orbs, Mint.
We gotta get some blue orbs for real.
Can I get a blue orb in the chat?
Oh, Lambrus with the blue orbs!
Thank you.
Check what the doctor of medicine is called.
Is it an indestition?
I can't say this word.
I don't know.
Maybe.
Great pronunciation.
Thank you!
I am an ENVTuber.
What are you talking about?
Who?
Spaghetti-chan.
Indiana gestation.
I think she took meds that make you sillier.
I can't wait to take these new meds, I says.
Little did I know they were the silliest meds.
When you're Indian, you're gestasting.
Larry!
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I'm gonna miss TikTok so much.
I go on TikTok...
I'm already crying.
I go on TikTok and I watch Offlane everyday.
Where else will I hear about the creature?
Or Larry?
Or the meatworm?
I'm so sad.
There's your problem.
I don't think I'll be good enough to sing tomorrow.
Indie station.
All aboard!
If you see David Lynch's ghost at the cafe on his way up, will you tell him hi, please?
I will.
I don't think that guy's a ghost, though.
That guy's probably already beyond.
Sad about TikTok?
I am.
You can call me silly.
You can call me so silly for being sad about TikTok.
But...
Oh my gosh.
I was talking to a friend about it.
Actually, when I was thinking about it, TikTok is my only...
First of all, I get a lot of inspiration from there.
I'll find games, I'll find skits that inspire me.
Things that inspire me to do stuff.
And then, also...
When I was talking to her about it, it's my one platform that I have no relation to VTuber stuff.
Get well soon!
Thank you!
It's my one place that I can super disconnect.
Now I'm just like, I don't have anything.
I don't have anything that I really need to turn my brain off from.
Because, you know, I go through Twitter and I'm just like...
I go through YouTube, everywhere.
So I'm just kind of...
Sorry, I was putting on chapstick.
It's like my one place where I get...
Obviously, my For You page is really catered to me, but it's all super duper random stuff.
I feel like with YouTube, it's just like, oh, I'm searching this specific thing.
And then I watch it, you know what I mean?
Nico Nico Douga.
I just like to be able to scroll and get a random thing.
I'll be like, oh, I'll get a random video about, I don't know, some lake.
Like Lake Baikal or something.
I'll be like, learn about that.
I'll be like, wow!
It helps me learn about stuff and just watch stuff that I wouldn't actively seek out because I wouldn't know that it exists, you know what I mean?
So I'm so bummed.
I haven't had the chance to say yeah, but thank you for any party last Saturday.
You made my first otaku event unforgettable.
Oh my gosh, I hope you had fun.
I feel so bad about any party though.
I was so sick.
And I like obviously didn't want to cancel.
So I was just like, oh, but I was like, I feel like I didn't do well at all.
So I feel so bad.
Helps to give you trivia knowledge.
Yeah, yeah.
You know, I know some people are just like, oh, TikTok is a cesspool, which it is.
Don't get me wrong.
But, but my for you page is pretty good.
I think it's a lot of pet videos and interesting facts about lakes.
Sorry, I'm really into like, actually, I was really I got into like the a lot of like medieval like side of stuff to.
Break the ice phantom collab with Mimi.
It's funny.
Mimi is not a ghost.
She's not a ghost.
But it's funny.
She actually messaged me last night.
Of course, I was watching her debut.
She's a baku, everybody.
She's a baku.
How do you say that?
Tapir?
Toupee?
But she she did message me.
She's so sweet.
She's I don't want to say what we talked about.
But she like, she's just such a she's just an absolute sweetheart.
So I, you know, if I if she ever wants to collab, of course, I want to collab with her too.
Kidding to throw you.
During you walk in brand new days and lifting oomph for Hoshiga has made my 2025.
Thank you, Minto.
Maybe those songs need to be spun more.
Or played more.
Give her MGS brain rot.
She was talking about games she was wanting to play.
I was taking everything in me to be like, hey, Nimi, have you heard of critically acclaimed series Metal Gear Solid?
Have you heard?
Tell her to play Twin Snakes.
Oh my gosh, I thought you said Twin Peaks and I was gonna go.
Oh, oh, sorry.
I know I'm yapping a bit.
It's because I haven't streamed very much this week.
And so I'm like, yep, yep, yep, yep, yep.
Somebody put in the comments, VOD watchers, skip to here.
Skip to here for the gameplay.
Is that how I feel about my Twitter?
Mostly just filled with art, cute animals, anime and video games.
Yeah.
I don't know.
It's like I didn't.
I didn't have like I never talked to anybody on.
I didn't like I had one person that I shared TikToks with, like on TikTok, like one person that I allowed to follow me, like my friend.
I know her.
And I never posted anything, but it's just so I don't feel like a lot of people are like, oh, I'm losing this community.
I don't really feel that.
I just feel sad that I'm losing, like, like I said, my one place where I can totally, completely disconnect.
So now I'm going to be even more crazed.
Oh, my God.
You see that Shuichi Ikeda officially retired from his role as Char?
What?
Kind of sad, but I'm really thankful for all his amazing work.
Wow, he's been at it for a long time.
I get to be here for one of these.
Thank you.
Hold on.
My phone just went.
Oh, OK.
There was nothing.
Minecraft collab.
I will ask her.
I will say, Nimi, do you want to play Minecraft with me?
We love listening to you.
Yep.
And I know everybody's very excited about the debut, Nimi debut.
But, you know, just a, just a reminder.
Obviously, I love Nimi, but a reminder for most VTubers don't go, you know, a lot of VTubers have that rule where it says, please don't go into or please don't say in chat, talk about other VTubers unless I bring them up first.
Kind of yada yada, you know, so I'm OK with talking about Nimi, of course.
She's my oshi.
But a, but a, not to, I know everybody is very excited and when you're very excited and when you're just like, I hope so and so collab, I hope so and so collab.
Just a, just remember to be kind of respectful about that rule.
I know it's very easy, though, to get so excited about something and want to ask and ask.
But a, I didn't get a plushie.
No, I was eating burrito.
I was eating a burrito when the shop went up and I didn't get to have, I didn't get to get the plushie.
Sold out so fast.
But I'm very happy for her that she had such a successful debut and she's so cute.
So, so, so, so, so, so happy.
Yeah, yeah.
Minky may yap, so true.
Minky may yap.
Sad you, oh, thank you, that reminds me, that reminds me actually.
Speaking of, speaking of some merch, I have two things to say about merch.
About my own merch.
Akari, your profile picture is so, so cursed.
Please, please.
First thing is that Mosobox posted a little picture on Twitter about maybe some orders getting prepped and ready.
But also, another thing, so, so if you ordered like the block or the plushie, the first round of plushies, I believe the second round of plushies were close to capping that.
So, if you have not gotten that, and if you are thinking, I really want the plushie, the second round is going to be capped soon.
Hot dog.
VOD watchers, skip to 0, 0, 0 for banging intro and fun goals.
Oh, wait, oh, oh, sorry, I just, wait, oh, the donors are behind.
Wait, oh, gosh, I read that wrong.
If you do decide to do TikTok marathon on Sunday, may I suggest you do it in 3D so we can see you laughing and wiggling to them.
I will consider.
Now you have a Switch 2 and we almost have Minecraft 2.
Switch 2 came out of nowhere.
I don't really follow leaks stuff or anything like that, so for me, it came out of nowhere.
People were like, um, it really didn't come out of nowhere.
Um, actually, I already knew all of this stuff.
Well, I didn't.
But, um, well, merch, merch, so, um, hopefully orders will be going out soon, so maybe pay attention to see if you get a little shipped.
I don't know if they do shipped emails.
I assume they do, but maybe be on the lookout for that.
And the second thing, second thing.
Any party was a blast, brain worms be gone.
Meat worm in my brain.
Um, okay.
Second thing is, um, that I know I just had.
Merch drop.
This is the only time I'm going to bring this up, but I know I just had merch drop not too long ago.
My first ever merch drop, but.
Sooner than you may think.
There may be.
Merch drop.
Maybe.
I say, I say sooner than it, but that's I'm going to say.
I'm going to say that it's different merch this time.
Different merch, like brand new.
I'm going to say that I don't plan on doing merch very like, you know, super duper often.
But the timing of this kind of, uh, because it took a while for the first round of stuff to, to, uh, to go out.
So don't, I hope you don't say that.
Don't think like, uh, oh my God, she's already putting out more merch.
My wallet.
She's going to be putting out merch every month.
No, no, no.
So don't worry.
Well, this next set of merch I'm very excited about.
There was one thing that I wanted to include that I don't think got done in time.
So it will be included in the next, next round of whatever, whatever I make.
Yeah, every week.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But, uh, you're going to make my wallet cry more than the average.
Don't super chat then!
But yeah, so.
I just wanted to give you guys a heads up.
It's, like I said, it's still a ways away.
It might coincide with a certain upcoming holiday.
That is all I will say.
Excited for MGS board game getting shipped out?
Oh my gosh, I did get that email too!
I got the Metal Gear board game like a year ago.
I pre-ordered it, so.
Wait, did I read that?
Milk day?
Oh, no, MLK day.
Milk.
Speaking of Gundam earlier, the new Gundam show has an insert song by VTuber.
I did see that!
Suisei, yeah.
Exciting stuff.
When's the Valentine's merch, and the summer merch, and the Halloween merch, and the anniversary merch, and the return anniversary...
No!
Stop it!
Stop it.
I also want to remind you guys that...
March 10th is Minto day.
Set your calendars.
We got to go big for Minto day this year.
I don't know what we're doing.
We got to figure out a day for Minky day too.
Thank you for the pink.
Also looking forward to more Minto...
Merch.
Minto, sorry.
I think...
I don't know if I'm actually dyslexic, but I think it's acting up really badly today.
I love watching you play DMC.
I grew up playing these classics.
Did you end up deciding to skip too?
No, Fib, I played it.
I played it.
I one-shotted it.
So it's just one stream.
You can just put it on in the background.
Since we're doing reminders, I'd like to remind everyone that I'm Minto Cute.
Thank you for the very spooky Super Chat, Murphy.
Don't buy Super Chats.
No snowball.
Don't do it.
Nicholas, call my bank for a loan.
No!
Thank you.
Time to refund my speed dating.
No!
Long awaited sequel to Minto merch.
Minto merch 2.
Don't forget the electric boogaloo.
Char's original VA just retired from the role.
Yeah, someone told me earlier.
How soon is that?
People are freaking out about it right now.
Did it just happen?
Five minutes ago, did they post the announcement?
Char's VA!
Char?
Char's VA is graduating!
Wait, she didn't start yet?
No, sorry.
I'm a yapping monster right now.
Okay.
Well, we can start now, I think.
I think we can start now.
Maybe I should have done the Super Chat.
Not Super Chat.
Free Chat.
Maybe.
Devil may cry.
Footage as gory, violent, will make your grandma cry.
Just see?
Thanks for the five gifted.
Green soup off a green woman.
Is the audio okay?
We must watch every time.
It might be in the way.
That might be better.
Evil.
Cloudy with a chance of devil crying.
Where are the meatballs?
Show me the meatballs!
Meatballs.
So-called legend.
Why is she saying it like that?
Ducky, thanks for the five gifted.
So-called legend.
She hates them.
Oh my god, Swirly.
I hope your luck turns around.
I'm gonna... That's...
That's not me.
That didn't happen.
He's so stiff when he falls.
It's like he turns into like...
He gets shot with like a...
Stiffy beam.
Skeletal Guzzler.
Wow, look at the membership.
Don't call it that.
Wait, what is that?
What did I say?
Wait, what did I say?
Is that not good?
No.
Not
a good word.
Wait.
Just ignore I said that.
Cut it from the tapes.
Editor.
Oh my god.
I don't know anything you guys.
I don't know anything.
Okay.
I made another save because I was scared.
I don't remember why.
Oh, because I was scared.
Okay.
Let's just go.
Let's just start the game.
What am I?
I'm on...
Oh, I cleared it.
I cleared it.
Okay.
I need scissor 61.
True.
Don't worry, the VOD watchers won't see that.
The gameplay starts now.
Link the gameplay here.
This is the mission.
Wait, what do you mean?
Don't say that.
I'm scared.
Why do you guys always say that?
Oh yeah, we have to look for the 13.
I'm scanning.
13.
Is it gonna be the blood?
Oh, he's trembling.
Little baby.
The blood will form 13.
13.
I need to pay attention to what's going on and not just looking for numbers.
The numbers.
Oh, I see it!
In the wall!
I saw it!
Chaos' warm welcome.
Oh no, battle of blood and of brothers.
Brothers.
Battle of blood and of brothers.
No.
No, he just...last time he absorbed the power of Beowulf.
Oh, bro.
What's that?
Oh gosh.
Oh not...oh wait.
Okay, I have 25,000 roars.
Hey Mint, are you free to hang out in exactly one month of random Friday and watch a movie Nacho Libre and then walk on the beach talking about Nacho Libre and then get dinner so we can keep talking about Nacho Libre?
I already watched Nacho Libre.
You weren't even there, fake fan.
Not of me, of Nacho Libre.
Blorb or porb?
That's a great question.
I think a porb.
But first also let me see my actions.
I must reflect.
This one I don't think I'm gonna...
There's agony and root drop.
Before I get anything...
Before I get anything, let's try the fight.
You know?
Before I get anything.
I think we'll try it.
I haven't seen the DMC anime.
Will it be a...
What does it...
What game does it...
What game does it animate?
You got me to redownload DMC5.
It's between...
Between 1 and 2.
I feel like you guys told me this before actually.
Sorry if I forgot.
Mission start.
I don't even know what I have.
What do I have?
Checkmate.
What the hell is this?
Oh my god.
I think I can shoot these things.
What am I...
I did not mean to do that.
Sorry.
Hold on.
Oh my god.
Oh, ok.
So red... I remember.
I remember.
Red means attack.
Ok.
I remember these guys.
I remember.
Ok.
Nice, nice.
He's about to attack.
Sorry.
I'm getting back into it, everybody.
Stinger!
Ok.
Nice.
Ouch.
I knew it was going to attack and I still went for it.
Because I'm an idiot.
I was going to say easy.
Oh shoot.
More?
Double?
Oh, door.
Let's get rid of these guys.
Ok.
Nice, nice, nice.
Can you stop crowning each other?
There we go.
Failure?
Ok.
Sorry.
We're back.
We're back in.
Sorry.
Spiral staircase.
They weren't kidding.
It's not a euphemism.
Real spiral staircase.
Ouch.
I hate this.
I
don't think I want to be doing this.
Oh my god.
I want out of here please.
Spider city.
Oh gosh.
They are so fast.
No, no.
That's not what I meant.
You know what?
Fine.
Wasn't they weak?
They are weak against the ice or something?
Jump!
Oh fire.
The complete opposite.
They are so rude.
No, no, no.
Oh my god.
We are killing them.
We are killing ourselves too.
Nice.
Oh, not nice.
Warp.
Oh shoot.
Fire that.
I'm not going to live.
I'll never live through this.
I wasn't ready.
I don't want the secret.
Please!
Let me out!
We are fine.
Again?
Anyway.
Just ignore the health.
Get back in there.
You can't make me.
What's in here?
Hell's highway.
Sounds trendy.
What's in there?
That's a blorb.
We need to get in there.
Do you think?
Oh no, I can't.
I was going to say the one that makes you fly.
Highway to hell.
I'm on the highway to hell.
Get it later?
Okay.
Who's going to ambush me in these hallways?
There it is.
It's this again.
Nice.
What if I just shoot from far away?
Wait.
There we go.
Blast!
Alright!
Oh yeah!
Oh no!
I can't believe this is working.
Sniper gameplay.
Yeah, it works.
If it works it...
I'll take that.
No, no, no.
I panicked.
It's working though.
For real.
I need to be able to see it.
Blip, blip!
It's working though.
Okay, I think I'm done.
Nice!
Sniper may cry.
Jack!
Oh Jack, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Okay, so we have a door there.
Hold on.
This is like the longest... the most doors I've seen in this game.
What is that up there?
Devil's door!
It pays to explore.
We love that.
Nice.
Well, if it isn't Saucy Jack.
That's truly Saucy Jack there.
Okay, so door here...
And what's down here?
Wait a second, sorry.
Why?
My camera's been a little weird lately.
Okay, and a door here.
Let's go into door number one.
That's...
Vestibule.
Oh, it's a light puzzle.
What do I need to light up?
Oh, the crack?
What is it?
Maybe...
Oh, it just resets the puzzle.
Okay, let's see.
Goes from there...
If I...
Oh, I see, I see, I see.
Okay, okay, okay.
I messed up.
Nice, okay.
We definitely probably need to get rid of this one.
So destroy.
Destroy.
Oh, it doesn't need to go to the crack?
The crack...
The crack is...
Different?
Wait, but then...
Then, what is this one?
Aura Halkon.
A perfectly formed piece of Aura Halkon.
I know what that is.
Said to open the door to the lair of judgment.
These names are starting to sound more and more Kingdom Hearts-y, I swear.
Did someone say the lair of judgment?
Didn't fall for the puzzle's tricks because she forgot it.
No, because I'm so smart.
Most likely.
I just saw the crack first.
I didn't need these stupid tricks.
I didn't need...
Ouch,
ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
I'm going back to gunslinger.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, it's healing them, you bastard!
There we go.
Where were you guys before?
Got him before he could do anything.
These...
These camera angles are really sending me...
Oh, shoot.
I did not realize.
I should have realized, but I'm stupid.
Stop healing them!
I hurt faster than they can heal.
I don't like this one, so we just keep shooting him.
I can't see!
Lips in your eyes.
OK, screw you, screw you, screw you!
Oh, I did it.
The eye can see.
Press the gunslinger button.
Minky, I'm glad you're getting better just in time for DMC3.
Also, today is my birthday.
Have a happy birthday song.
Of course, it's the best!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Saiko!
Happy birthday!
Time.
Sexy lion.
I didn't buy anything before.
I think I'm still trying to decide.
That was a devil trigger?
Why did you give me that?
What is this?
Offer up the ore, halcon and proceed...
Wait!
I didn't get to explore the rest!
OK, nevermind.
Goodbye.
Hold on.
Hold your horses.
How do I get to the blorb?
I would have to use this guy, but...
I can barely do...
I can barely do five.
Read the file.
Thanks for the super chat!
I hope you're OK.
OK.
Yeah,
some blorbs just don't need to be gotten.
So true.
So true!
This is scaring me, guys.
Save.
Let's just try.
Tell me how hard is he really...
Is there something missing?
Wow.
Chat!
No, Dante!
No!
Yeah, it doesn't matter who's blood goes in.
No, please!
Please!
Please don't come over here, Virgil!
Oh my God!
I parried him!
Because I'm so good at this game!
That's not what I meant.
Oh my... He's parrying me.
Oh,
stop parrying me, you little...
OK,
that's when I can get him.
After he does his little tricks.
Now I'm motivated!
No!
Stop, please!
Do your little trick, please.
Oh my God.
He parries so...
Oh, shoot.
I didn't parry him there.
Oh, damn!
OK.
I'm just doing whatever.
Wait, I don't know.
I couldn't tell if he was... Oh, damn.
OK, OK.
Oh my God.
Chill
out!
I'm gonna die.
There we go.
It's OK.
It's OK!
OK, OK, OK.
I don't think Stinger really works.
OK.
I'm scared of Phase 2.
Ah, damn!
There we go.
Damn it!
Damn!
Oh, shoot.
I tried to...
Ah, damn it!
Oh my God!
The timing is so... small.
I get two feet from him!
Maybe fight back.
Oh no, what is this?
What is this?
He's also got a demon form!
OK.
He double triggered.
OK, that doesn't do anything.
That's fine.
I was just trying to build up double trigger for me.
OK, OK, OK.
He heals in DTN?
No, shut up.
Oh, shoot.
I parried.
Oh,
shit!
Do I
have any items?
Glad to hear your voice is doing better.
Thanks.
Who took a mickey?
I don't know.
Thanks for joining MappaShift.
Welcome to MappaShift!
Don't!
It won't be enough!
Give it a few more tries first.
OK, still I feel like this is...
I will die, but I feel like this is a nice try, second round, you know?
Don't give yourself a bronchitis too!
I don't have a bronchitis, I have a boonkitis.
Sorry, it looks better in text than it says saying out loud.
Virgil's tooth theme is the one they use in MV...
Oh, is that the Marvel vs.
Capcom?
Now known as the theme of your opponent is going to kill your entire team.
Oh, I wish.
I don't know why I tried the stinger there.
I just instinctively go for the stinger sometimes.
NT, NT, NT, NT, NT.
Blackshot still built DT.
Is that true now?
I don't know.
I'm on part 5 of this playthrough of this game and I didn't know that.
That's OK, that's OK.
Mito screamed louder than last time she met Doki.
What do you mean?
I think it's because my settings are a little different.
I will have to adjust them a little bit.
Actually, some people may not know but I got a new computer as of yesterday.
Did you know Ace Combat 7 just hit 6 million units sold yesterday?
I did!
You guys saved my franchise.
Happy for you, Nan.
That was the most heartfelt and primal scream of fear I've ever heard in my life.
I was scared.
I have a new PC and so I was setting stuff up with everything today.
So my sound settings might be a little bit different.
I apologize in advance if they sound not as good.
But my PC is so pretty.
Actually, there's one thing... I do have to take it back.
Because there's one thing that isn't working.
It's a minor thing.
Obviously, it's still usable.
I bought all the parts and then basically took it somewhere to get put together.
Because I don't know how to do that.
But yeah.
Assembled.
Yeah, assembled.
Are the cables bundled super neatly?
They are.
Maybe once it's completely working, I will take a photo.
And it's also very quiet.
Oh my gosh.
My last computer had issues with the fans rumbling and rattling.
Also, the fans in general were kind of loud.
Even streaming, I don't hear it at all.
I don't hear it.
Streaming setups are kind of beefy, especially as a VTuber.
And I don't hear anything.
It's so quiet.
It's so nice.
Hmm.
Yeah, I'm really happy about it.
And everything is running so smoothly.
I was having issues with my monitors.
Every time my monitors in my old PC would go to sleep, when they turned back on, they would resize my entire screen.
They would disconnect and reconnect.
And no matter what I did on my computer, it wouldn't fix it.
And I tried so much stuff.
And so, some windows, it would resize and then I would have to fix everything in OBS.
Because it would resize stuff and then stuff in OBS would break.
And it was just frustrating me.
Because I would have to re-fix everything every day.
It was so annoying.
Sorry, a little mini rant before virtual again.
And so, now I don't have that problem anymore.
I'm so, so happy.
I tested it earlier.
It didn't resize anything.
I'm so happy.
I'm getting 30 burgers for dinner.
Who wants what?
I want a burger.
I want a cucumber on my burger, please.
Cucumber burger, please.
What am I doing with my old PC?
I'm keeping it as a backup, actually.
Just in case anything happens, you know.
I think it's always safe.
Because I actually don't have a PC that would be like a backup in case...
Wait, wrong chat.
No!
Mustache man, no!
Thank you for the...
Akadono... I mean, Zaka Super, thank you!
Thank you!
So, no burgers?
Yeah, wait.
What about the burgers?
But yeah...
Better PC to play old games, better Minecraft.
I wonder.
I wonder now though if this PC could play Indiana Jones.
I want five guys in me and five guys out of me.
That's called the...
The digestive system.
Guys, don't say ew, it's natural.
All humans poop, don't they?
You eat the burger and then you poop out the burger.
You better hope you poop out the burger.
What?
It has to come out somewhere?
This is the welcome to...
Biology with Minto.
Biology.
No, sorry, I meant...
Bintology.
Ghosts don't poop?
No.
No, no, no.
All food, basically, is like, you know...
Well, like, I show you my legs on stream, but like, I usually...
Have like a little wispy tail, you know?
It takes a lot of energy to have legs.
So...
No bumhole.
Just a little wisp bottom, you know?
No,
I'm not gonna show you my wisp tail on stream.
What the...
That's so embarrassing.
What is this room called?
The lab of judgment?
I like the biblically act...
I forgot I was fighting someone right now.
Oh, I meant to jump.
Not doing so hot.
I don't know how to get out of that once I'm in it.
I can't jump or do anything.
Shihan, welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Oh, you son of a bitch.
Gosh.
At
least he doesn't avoid this.
I don't know if this does anything, but it does build DT at the very least.
How do I... I know how to taunt.
You taunt me, I taunt you.
Come on!
Nice!
Nice dodge.
Come on, weep.
I'm trying to do slow and steady, you guys.
I know I'm not being very aggressive.
I'm still like... I'm just letting him stall out his DT.
I know he heals.
He doesn't heal a ton, it seems.
There we go.
Let's bait him.
Ah, shoot!
Ok, now we gotta...
We gotta make him waste out... Run out of DT for him.
I don't want him getting any hits on me.
We just let him...
Where are you going?
There we go.
I'm actually gonna let mine go for a bit.
Why isn't it working anymore?
You bastard!
You bastard, you...
Slow and steady, slow and steady, slow and steady.
You think your name is Wimp at this point?
Wimpy, wimpy!
Ok, I'm building up a little bit more.
A little bit more, a little bit more.
Oh no, no, no!
No, no, no, no!
Shoot!
No, no, no!
Oh my God!
Shoot!
Oh shoot, this is bad.
Everything is bad here.
That was not good at all.
That was so...
That was so bad, that was so bad.
We were just standing there.
Come on, Wimpy!
Punch in air?
For real?
I have more weapons.
I know, but like...
This one has air.
This one puts me in the air.
It's the best one I have to avoid his attacks.
Oh gosh, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
I'm not gonna beat this, but...
Oh
gosh, scary, scary, scary.
Why can't I get more DT, please?
Are you serious?
Too far away?
I wasn't... I was as far away as I was before though.
There we go.
That's better.
Oh come on, you bastard!
You bastard!
Good.
Yeah, I feel like I was probably spamming the taunt, but that's okay.
That's okay.
I'm wondering if I should buy more... plorb?
Should I buy the plorb?
I don't know.
Yes.
Plorb or plorb.
Eenie meenie miney mo, catch a tiger by his toe, if he hollers let him go, my mom said to pick the very best one and you are it!
Thank you, pyrobot.
That's sounding healthy.
Hang in there and kick his butt.
Thank you!
30,000.
It hurts.
It hurts bad.
Nice.
Can I just stand there?
I'm right in front of you.
Nice, nice, nice.
OK.
Alright, alright, alright.
Come here.
Where am I?
Come on.
I'm scared.
Oh shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Oh shoot.
Ah!
No!
Shit, shit.
Oh, oh, oh.
It's right in front of me.
Phase 2, phase 2, phase 2.
Ah shit.
Shit, shit, shit!
OK.
They're nice, nice.
We're full.
They'll run out.
Eventually.
I don't want him to heal, but...
I can't get a good angle.
Give me a good angle, please.
Just run out, or...
Just run out.
What
the hell is this thing, anyway?
Scum!
Scum.
OK, this is good, this is good.
Ah shit, shit, shit.
Ah!
You motherfucker.
I wasted it.
No!
Now he's healing!
Come on.
Ah!
Damn, that was so...
Please let me... No!
No, please let me have some iframes, please!
OK, OK, OK.
Alright, alright, alright.
Scum!
I'm missing my opportunities!
OK, OK, OK.
Just a little bit more, just a little bit more.
Really?
Ah, I miss...
I miss, I miss, I miss him.
Come on, man.
Ah, damn.
No!
I'm so close!
In fact, let me just do this.
Run, run, run!
Oi!
Fuck you.
I'm gonna lose my brain cells.
Ah, he healed so much.
This sucks.
Ha!
Let's go!
Yeah, we didn't need the Vital Star.
Little sucker.
Oh!
Damn, lady.
Oh,
no!
This clown, literally!
You!
Hold on, I'm gonna get a cough drop real quick.
I have another thing.
Daddy!
Yeah,
I whooped his butt.
Oh!
Of course.
There he is.
We all knew it.
Ew!
Wait, were they working together this whole time?
Oh my God!
Hmm...
Ah?
Oi!
Was it a hallucination?
Like a...
Not a hallucination, a little...
It wasn't real?
It's the same dude!
Oh!
Oh my God!
Oh, in the butt!
Oh, nevermind, in the leg.
It's our...
I only fought you once.
You don't dress like this normally, but it suits you.
Ew!
What?
Oh!
Jinx.
Haha, yeah baby!
Oh no!
Oh no, baby!
Oh boo!
Oh he's breakdancing!
Oh my God!
Blue cheese, thank you for the 20 gifted!
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
Oh no!
Virgil!
Yeah!
We did it!
Nice!
Nice.
Noice, noice, noice.
I guess I gotta go now.
No!
Noice.
Buoy for bueno.
Yeah!
Si!
One thing I wanna say...
For people...Oh my goodness, I feel like I have to say this every stream.
I know I'm passive in fights sometimes, but it's just how I play.
I have to warm up a bit and kind of read how things are before I go all crazy willy nilly.
So you don't have to be in chat being like screaming...
Finally, be more aggressive.
Stop being so passive.
You don't have to be so aggressive in chat, okay?
So, you know, it's just how I play.
And if that bothers you, you don't have to watch, you know?
It's because if I go in all crazy, I get flustered and then I end up making crazy mistakes.
So I kind of gotta like back off and read the situation and then go in and then back off and read the situation.
It's just how I gotta do.
So sorry.
I'll
literally explode.
Gotta find your bearings first.
Yeah, it's just kind of how I do.
I know it's not everybody.
Everybody gets impatient.
I'm sorry.
Wow, it looks like a cannon.
If we're going to... If we're opening the gates of hell, why are we going up?
Is it just because it's more epic to fight on top of a big tower?
Okay.
RGB tower.
You should watch some combo map videos when you finish the game so you can see smoking sexy style.
Play how you learn.
Thanks Brandon!
Doesn't... What about her leg?
She's walking it off.
Tis a flesh wound.
Trickster Dash gives a lot of iframes.
Seems to suit your playstyle more.
I'm so sorry for backseeking.
No worries.
The reason I...
Here, let's wait for the cutscene.
Are we going to get Virgil?
The reason... Oh, 14!
The reason I sometimes don't use Trickster is because I find the dash to be a little slow.
So, charge upward toward the sky.
Drive!
And that's it.
Nice, I got a good amount from that.
Sorry.
Okay, let's go!
Judgment ruins.
The lair of judgment.
Judgment.
Any rorbs or...
Bless you!
Thank you!
Anything to be discovered, I feel.
Is this all just platforming?
If so, I apologize in advance.
If this is all just a platforming part.
What is this?
Flash Gauntlets and Greaves!
This set boosts Dante's attack and speed, making him a lethal weapon!
And there we have the full wheel!
Sorry, I know I'm blocking it, but...
We fight like Virgil, how he fought.
Oh, okay, that's actually like...
That's so fun!
Wait, I want a time thing now.
Hold on, is there one over here?
Can we exit the door?
Oh, you're so silly, game.
Wait, that's not what I expected.
Hold on.
Do I not go manually up, like up east?
Wait, then what's up there?
It pays to go around.
Bale Wolf.
That's not what I wanted to do at all.
Dante, remember the basics of CQC!
Nicholas, thanks for the ping!
I'm here to kill Chaos.
The quest is to kill Chaos.
I can't stand Chaos.
Chaos pisses me off.
Chaos has a loser nerd with no friends.
Mom says it's my turn to kill Chaos.
Chaos hates capitalism and yet he participates in it.
Ironic.
It has air hike too.
Beast uppercut.
Let's do it!
Ok,
hold on.
I don't want to fall off.
Please.
Please, can I not go up there?
I feel like there is a secret.
Congrats on beating easily two of the hardest bosses in the whole game.
No way Virgil was supposed to be that hard.
There is an invisible wall.
The game is...
Forb...
The game is forbidding me from exploring but that won't stop me from finding the robes!
Like, I'm not saying it wasn't difficult, but...
I just...
You know, I just felt like I played it slow.
That's why it took me so long.
I got him in three tries!
Oh.
This way.
Sorry, my nose is all gross now.
Hold on.
Because I sneezed.
Did you hear that come out?
So much ectoplasm.
Ugh.
But,
it's not...
It's not bad looking.
I know that I...
You know how like, when you're sick it's a different color?
That happens to humans too, right?
Nice and minty.
Okay.
Playing passive is Virgil's weakness.
Apparently, huh?
Forb.
Top obsidian path.
We're in Minecraft now?
Wait, was there nothing else out here?
What's this?
Oh!
Oh, we're here!
It's all broken.
Oh yes, we've been in here!
Oh my god, wait, oh wow!
Cool!
Missed the diamond pickaxe.
Oh no!
Okay, cool.
Is there stuff?
He knows you're trying to point.
No.
Hey mint chat.
Hello!
Sorry, I know I keep jumping around.
I'm just looking for stuff.
I'm a little bit of a loot goblin.
I wanna have Beowulf.
Actually, sorry, I'm not gonna have Beowulf installed immediately.
So we can have the double air hike.
Does this lead to that blorb?
Nope, it doesn't.
Maybe not.
What the hell is this?
I don't think... I don't think I should be getting close to this thing.
Oh, it's this guy!
Oh, ow!
Oh my god.
I have to attack him from behind.
Shoot.
Nice.
Where are you?
There you are.
Come here.
More?
Oh, more?
Okay, just kidding.
Come here.
I need one of you at a time.
Why are you so fast?
Why are you like this?
Hello?
I'm just trying to see your behind.
How many are there?
Oh my god, there's like three of them.
I'm not very good at these guys, sorry.
Please, please, may I see your bum?
Please, may I see your bum?
Please, please, I want to see the spiky bum.
Oh, please.
Please, I need it.
Please, show me.
You, come here.
It's just a little wallflower, that's what he is.
Yeah, little wallflower you.
He's freaking out.
He's like, I've never been this close.
They're so shy.
Stop.
Please, please, please, let me see your bum.
Oh, you know what?
It was worse, it was worse, it's fine.
Oh my god, oh my god, I'm such a dummy.
There we go, finally, my god.
These guys are such a pain in my bum.
They're so annoying.
So we don't have to do this over again, okay.
No, they're a pain in their bum.
Is that your temperance?
Yeah, we're here.
Yeah, I feel like I'm... I don't know where I'm going.
Okay.
Oh, that's just a light, okay.
This is the right way?
Okay, thank you for confirming, I appreciate it.
Orange?
Oh, I...
Gales of flame?
Oh, okay.
Okay,
I don't feel like really...
That doesn't even hit him, that's so lame.
I can't stand doing those, sorry.
I'd rather have a seize... Oh, that item down there, how do I get that?
Push?
I didn't really need that, but...
Minto gaming.
Tram time.
I love getting ambushed.
I'm punching you.
Go to hell!
Ouch.
I need to learn what the moveset is for this.
I don't like this one.
Oh, shoot.
Please, leave me alone, I hate you, stupid Reaper.
I fear the Reaper.
Oh my gosh, why can't I parry that?
There we go, nice.
Let's just keep it for now.
We are back here.
How many robes do I got?
Oh, wrong button.
So close, so close.
I have 19,000.
More cowbell.
Time to fight Beowulf again.
I want to use Beowulf more, so I want to...
Actually, before I do that, let's read the file.
Before I forget.
Alright, combo one.
X, X, X.
X, X, pause.
X, X.
I have not done that one yet.
Pause.
X, X.
X, X, pause, X.
So we have triple X.
X, X, pause.
X, X.
Do a fancy kick.
Is that one good?
Killer bee.
Jump and X in the air.
Straight.
Yeah.
What's the go to hell one?
Hyper fist.
No, I haven't done it.
Repeatedly press X while executing type 2 combo.
This one?
Or...
Was it this one?
What's the go to hell?
Go to hell.
Go to hell is sword master.
So X, X, pause, X, X and then I just keep mashing X.
I can do that.
My friend is a long time wisp and it's his birthday.
Can I get an MGS happy birthday and a present for when he wakes up?
Oh, as a present.
Huh?
I don't know what that was.
Weird?
I don't know.
Okay.
Ah...
Oh, happy birthday to Yuro.
Yes.
Happy birthday.
Congratulations.
Happy birthday with salutations.
Happy birthday.
May your sky stay blue.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday Yuro and good morning Minto.
Junto, is that how you say your name?
Your good friend.
X, X...oh, that's the wrong thing.
X, X, pause, X, X.
I don't think I did it.
I'm trying to...I am mashing it all the way.
And Sword Master is Kamehameha.
A long time whispering.
I love your awesome Minto.
I love you, your awesome Minto.
Thank you for the MGS birthday.
Oh, you're here.
Wait.
Yuro Juggler, it's you.
Happy birthday.
When you see the fast multi-kicks, you got to mash like three times faster.
Oh, okay, okay.
Oops, no.
X, X, pause, X, X.
I don't think I'm mashing fast enough.
X, X, pause.
Am I doing it correct?
I did it!
Oh man, I had to put the controller down in my lap.
Oh my goodness.
You have to mash it like MGS Torture Sequence, for real.
What is this?
I don't like...
What the hell is that?
Oh!
It's just like... Okay, it's just like the other things.
Horse.
Does this place have any rhyme or reason to it?
Like this...
More!
What?
Is it more horsies?
Let me out!
Oh no, it's these guys.
Okay, okay, hold on.
I'm just gonna do this, sorry.
I don't feel like dealing with it.
Just die!
I don't feel like dealing with you.
Why are you shooting both directions?
There is only one thing...
Is it because of me?
Damn horse!
You damn horse!
Okay, let me out!
No!
More horse!
I tried to jump!
What was I on?
Oh, I think I was on Gunslinger.
I tried moving.
These damn things are gonna be the death of me!
No more horse!
No more horse please!
No more!
I don't want a horse around anymore!
Okay, so...
What?
At least... Oh my gosh!
I didn't even know you were...
Screw you!
Alright, more!
Oh no!
You jerk!
At least I'm getting lots of warms.
This one doesn't open.
This one open.
I'm confusion.
What is that?
Oh no, it's this guy!
Okay, take care of him first.
Okay, nice.
Ah, shoot!
Ah!
Oh,
I did it.
Nice!
Everything opened up.
Where did I come from?
Where do I go?
What can I do?
This one doesn't have a little circle bottom.
Warbs in the air?
Can I get them?
I got them.
That's where I came from.
You!
You from before!
Nice!
Attacking made me avoid that.
That's so great.
Oh shoot, shoot, shoot!
Oh my god, I ran right into it.
It's so messed up.
Gosh.
Oh, he's still here!
You're a healie!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I don't like this area anymore!
What?
All this more warb... I mean...
It's not even a blorb proper.
It's a fragment.
Did I make it out?
Is there anything special to find in here?
Should I go back?
Or is there anything special?
Two, two, two.
Or is this out?
Fragment.
What do the blorbs taste like?
Probably blueberry.
I think you got the special things.
Maybe?
Wait, is this the exit?
Please say yes.
If anybody knows.
Where did all the backseaters go?
Before you were all like, I'm telling you how to play Minto.
Now you won't tell me if I'm out.
Oh yes?
Ok.
Thank you.
Bye bye.
I don't think this is helping us get to the top of the tower.
We're just running around.
Are we not?
What?
How long is this level?
How?
Action.
I think I will...
I can't decide if I want to have it for the poor, but what if I...
What if I...
Aerohike is really good on Beowulf because of the dive kick.
Ok, I'll get it.
Double jump.
I'll get it, I'll get it, I'll get it.
That's what I was...
Yes!
I am broke!
There's items somewhere.
Collect items!
I'm getting one guide.
This is this area.
And then there's a door over here, right?
No?
Just the way I came out.
Oh no, nevermind.
Oh no!
Oh, is this area...
What do I have on?
I'm going to punch you in the...
You're going to punch me in the face.
I don't want to die!
Oh my god!
Oh damn!
Oh my gosh, thank you.
Oh mighty game.
What the hell is that?
This cancels them out too.
Come on!
Damn, it's really, really powerful.
Do I go in the light or is that the trickster man?
Little joke guy.
Oh my god!
It's basically Stinger, but...
Oh my gosh, I should have upgraded it.
It's basically Stinger!
Oh my god, he cancels them out!
This is so awesome!
Oh my god!
It's the trickster man!
Or is it the way?
I don't know.
The light is...
They always say don't go into the light.
Are you telling a ghost to go into the light?
Are you telling me...
Meet Phantom, a ghost.
Are you saying go into the light, people!
Yes.
Love planet.
This is where we met the sexy lady?
No, what is this place?
We are back at the strip club.
From the very beginning?
Who would have thunk?
That we would be back here.
That's craziness.
Wait, can we go into the other room?
This room is so sexy.
It was over here, right?
The door?
Yeah.
Bullseye.
Sweet dreams.
What did I just reset?
Is there a puzzle in here?
What did I just do?
I remember destroying this room many times.
I did for that secret mission.
I remember.
It's wide.
Yeah baby!
Freaking Rorb Central.
The good old days.
What part was that?
Back when little Mijo...
There we go.
I think I got everything we can get in here.
Oh wait, destroy the chair.
Nice.
Destroy the jukebox.
Big money.
Sorry I'm backtracking a little bit.
Nevermind.
Let's go towards the tower.
What does this do?
I remember skipping that area before too.
The game lets you wander off the beaten path and won't tell you you're going the wrong next few missions.
Be careful.
Thank you!
Actually I really appreciate that.
It's not that I'm tired of the game obviously, but I'm on part 5 of this game.
I'm ready to go to the next game.
It seems a lot of people really like...
Devil May Cry 5?
What was it trying to do?
This bike is like, I'm trying to climb up here by myself.
Yeah!
I love wooing Dante!
Oh no.
Not a woo moment.
I think I might add that to the dono sound.
You got this Dante!
I wish I could one shot them like this.
God
he's so cool.
Good job Dante.
Our bike!
Whatever.
Nice!
That was quite the long mission.
I mean I know I got distracted a little bit, but there was a lot going on in that mission.
Nice!
The motorcycle was supposed to be another weapon, but it was too complicated to implement into the game.
Would've been so cool.
It would've!
My opinion on DMC5 would get me crucified.
Especially considering my love for DMC Devil May Cry.
Now that's a...
That's a spicy opinion.
Wait, what?
We're on...
14?
Or 13?
Which chapter are we on?
15.
Don't spoil DMC5.
I'm not seeing any spoilers.
Rather, I have not read them if they are there, but don't spoil!
Oh, I missed the 15.
Dang it.
Every time I see him throw the handles of the bike as a kid I expected the handlebars to explode like in Spongebob.
I can see it.
I missed the 15.
It was in the branches.
I see, I see, I see.
Okay, I'm gonna get some more water.
I need some more water real quick.
15.
How many are in this game?
How many chapters?
We're definitely not gonna finish it today, but I'm just wondering.
20.
So just 5 more.
6 more.
20 missions, but 2 are boss battles alone.
Got it, got it, got it.
Thank you.
Okay.
The last 3 are hard.
That's okay.
I figured today... I'm still gonna play mission 15.
I figured today might be a little shorter and then...
Next week I'm going to be...
Basically every game that I am up in the air with.
Like this game and Indiana Jones and...
Actually that might be it, but I'm gonna endurance until I beat them.
Yeah, yeah.
I wasn't able to catch you on my V-Day, but it was earlier this week.
Thanks for another awesome year.
Oh, I'm sorry, I missed a zip spot.
Okay, I'll sing a happy birthday and then I'll go get some water.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear 6th spawn.
Happy birthday!
Yeah, I figure with the...
With the days off that I have...
That I've been taking this week, my voice should be...
And I sound mostly okay.
I still sound a little bit...
A little bit rough.
But I think my voice should mostly be okay next week.
And if I keep taking the medicine, which I will take when I get back...
When I get the water, I should be okay.
I think too.
Endurance a little bit next week.
Not tomorrow.
I don't know why I was gonna say that.
Yeah.
Okay.
We are back.
I get water and I also go to the ghost's room.
So, you can take a little break too.
But don't go far.
No!
Oh no!
Wait, why isn't it the font that I use?
Wait, no, it changed my font.
There it is.
Okay.
Where are we?
Welcome back.
Thank you.
Sorry about the break.
Alright.
My tea might be...
A little hot.
Missions.
Customize?
How much do I have?
Sorry, I know I always check.
Okay, not a lot.
That's fine.
Mission start.
What's going on?
Heaven?
An angel?
What's this?
Hole?
Worst enemy in the game?
Oh my god!
Holy shit, I thought I was going to fall off.
What the hell?
Why is it getting bigger?
Hello?
What is happening?
I don't like these guys.
Dante!
Oh my god.
Dante says screw it all.
Oh, I forgot that I'm not in Sword Master.
There we go.
Oh my god.
Dante, don't miss.
Don't die at the wall.
I was waiting for the angel.
What the hell?
Sorry, hold on.
What is going on with my computer?
Why did I clip out?
What the heck is going on?
What happened?
My computer is lagging like crazy.
What is happening?
I lost chat.
What's happening?
My computer is lagging like crazy.
Am I okay?
What is going on?
Why?
I can't see you guys anymore.
I can see you through OBS, but that's it.
I always have to have computer issues.
Why me?
Everything I try to do never fixes it.
I can't bring you guys back because you're off screen.
Basically, my left monitor is the Switch.
My right monitor is where I was reading chat.
And I don't know where you guys went.
Sorry.
Let me just fight these guys and hopefully my computer doesn't bug up anymore.
I'll look into it afterwards.
Is it dead?
Why can't he aim?
Why can't you aim Dante?
Hey!
Horse!
Everything is breaking you guys.
Sorry, I'm so frustrated.
Tech issues are so the worst annoyingness ever.
Oh my god, not you bitches.
Fire!
Oh my god.
I don't want to do
damage from the freaking angel things.
I jumped!
I don't know how to get out of that, honestly.
I'm just gonna fight.
I'm just gonna...
I don't care.
I'm so mad right now.
I'm sorry.
Stupid!
Which way?
I came in through there.
Is this anything?
No?
Just lighting up?
Don't give up Mito!
Remember, you are the strongest ghost!
Thank you!
What is this?
Looks like an elevator control switch, but something is missing.
There are three indentations to insert objects into.
Three?
This way I guess first.
Is this the only way I can go?
Forbidden land.
Hell yeah.
Give me all them robs!
Let the hate flow through you.
What the?
Welcome?
I don't remember that.
Is that always there?
Oh no!
An energy source has been activated.
That's the thing we were inside, right?
It's when you came out of Leviathan.
A large snapping sound, like two parts locking together can be heard from beyond the wall.
That's sick!
Secret robes, eh?
I know how to find them, don't I?
Up we go.
I'm guessing this allowed us to go a different direction?
No.
Like two things snapping together.
I am good at finding these robes, eh?
I knew this was a thing!
Massive force is shaking the tower.
No more horse.
It feels like the whole tower is rotating.
So if I go back in here...
Is this different at all or is it still the same?
Still the same.
So the door just changes and we go to a different space.
I figured that was the case, I just wanted to confirm.
No!
Different place!
Wait, don't rotate?
Just kidding.
No breakdown.
I mean, yes, I am having a breakdown.
Ahaha!
Come on,
bird!
This is where I switched it to, right?
Oh my god.
Go up?
Where was the door?
Oh gosh.
Over here.
Alright.
Your bum!
Show it to me!
Come on!
I had it.
There we go.
Some metal gears.
Come here.
Nice, nice.
Nice.
Alright.
Run.
Oh, come here.
Come here.
Come here, come here.
Don't push, don't push now.
Nice.
Come here.
He's getting shoved around.
Okay, we got him.
Like that.
Oh, oh, oh, oh gosh.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
Oh gosh!
Nice.
Why is this one so slow?
Okay.
Nice.
The first thing!
The Orihalcon fragment.
Oh, it got broken.
It's just like Inuyasha.
You guys were in sync before.
What happened?
Okay.
Nice.
Are you kidding me?
Okay.
Cool.
Missed blorb?
No.
I will not miss a blorb.
Okay, I will become the world's greatest wall climber.
Wall hacks please.
Okay.
Nice.
Come on.
There we go.
Yippee!
I think that's two out of four now.
Okay, now we go back and we spin.
Oh, ouch!
Are you kidding me?
Why is everything in this freaking place out to murder?
Okay, can you leave me alone for like a minute?
Okay.
Alright, next door!
I imagine, right?
I imagine we go this way again, right?
I imagine.
Ouch!
Oh my god, it is so much damage.
No.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Is it the other door?
Other door.
Door with a circle.
Okay.
Understood.
Leave me alone, leave me alone, leave me alone, leave me alone.
Ouch!
Leave me alone.
Please, I ask for nothing.
I am simple.
I just need to be left alone.
Please, birth my own thoughts.
Please.
Okay, we are... Oh, music is still happening.
What's here?
Oh, what?
Does this work?
Damn.
Oh, it's the guys that turn around.
They go up and...
They go back and forth.
Okay, you come over.
How do you do that?
It's sword master.
It's okay.
We have a lot of space in here.
I could... I'll just wait for him to come back.
There is the other one.
Again.
Can you ignore them?
You know, you probably can.
But they are so... Okay.
Nevermind.
At least I got some health from it.
What's this?
Oh, this is the thing I need.
Okay, wait.
I'm confused.
So do I spin this and it rotates the clock room?
And then I go back to the clock room?
And then I...
Then I go rotate in the clock room?
Then I come back here?
And then... Oh my god.
So when we rotate we just...
Wait, so do I even go through here?
Where am I?
I go in here.
Yes.
Okay.
Little babies?
Oh my god, more.
My favorite one!
Oh my gosh, please.
Give me my robes, thank you.
Nice.
And she is gonna explode the babies.
No?
No babies?
Nobody is for granted?
That's always my biggest fear if I ever...
If I ever kill a spider.
I'm always so scared of the babies.
The potential babies coming out.
No babies.
Oh there it is.
I got another fragment.
Okay.
It was there the whole time.
Don't be extra, Dante.
Don't be... I wish I could see...
I wish I could see...
I wish... I don't know if the guy respawned or not.
Yeah, I already turned this circle.
My
god!
He was right there.
Okay, bye.
See ya.
Twelve thousand.
We can learn drive.
No, that's a lie.
Sorry.
Straight level two.
Might be good, right?
Since it's basically stinger but with my fists.
Sorry, I was thinking of the uppercut.
But I need to learn how to do...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I need to learn how to do...
The kick.
We know straight.
Air hike.
Just be in mid-air, yeah.
But isn't there a dive kick?
What is that one?
This one.
Press X in mid-air.
Am I not doing it right?
Wait.
Oh X!
I was pressing A.
I see.
Your poor PlayStation brain.
I know.
PlayStation brain real.
What the...
Oh that's my shadow.
I thought something was crawling up the wall.
How was my shadow doing that?
Crazy.
Okay, so I'm guessing I...
Hold on.
I see him over there.
I...
Look how many there are.
I'm so confused about this part.
I already spun it, but the spin led me here.
And then do I...
Please.
Go through the blue doors.
No spin.
Okay.
Thank you for helping me guys.
This part is confusing me a little bit.
Lots and lots of roars.
Very delicious.
Can I jump in here?
Nope.
There we go.
Okay.
What is here?
What is this?
Oh these guys that move when I don't look at them, right?
Oh my god.
I'm gonna use this one on them.
Okay.
I don't look.
I'm not looking.
Where'd you go?
Oh my god.
I'm not looking.
What's happening to me?
It's eating my devil trigger!
Get me out of here.
I'm so dead.
Rip Bozo!
El Bozo!
Oh, I'm back here.
Okay, thank you for being so generous to me, game.
What am I using?
I don't remember how to beat these guys.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, I killed one!
I killed one!
Yippee!
Okay.
I just have to get through here.
Now for the hard part.
Exactly.
Can I jump?
Can I trickster in the air?
No, I can't.
Okay.
Okay, we made it through one!
Okay, we made it through two!
Okay, we did it!
We made it!
What's in here?
Nothing?
Really?
Okay.
Okay!
Now we go back!
Try using Beowulf attack.
Wait, Beowulf attack on air to make it.
Like...
Let's go!
We did it!
Alrighty.
Now...
I punch back...
It was this one, right?
This one?
No, no.
Stop it, Dante.
Whose blood is that?
One more.
Wait, where am I?
Is this the eleventh?
Wait, if I go through here...
Devil Sprout lift.
What's here?
I'm getting lost.
No, no, no.
Okay, no more exploration.
I'm done exploring.
It's play to win.
Spin to win, everybody.
Spin to win.
The whole tower is shaking.
So this should lead us back to the staircase then.
So we can put in the amulet.
Wait...
What?
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh shit.
How did you get me?
Jump and kick.
I can't.
Okay, okay, okay.
Now I can.
I don't want to die to spiders again.
Nice suit.
I know you're about charged enough, but...
Are we gonna...Oh, there's more.
Oh my god, there's more.
Of course there's more.
There's so many more.
TT, please.
Please let me TT.
Oh my god, please attack anything.
Wasted moment.
Any babies?
Am I backtracking?
Is that what I'm doing?
No way.
Am I backtracking?
Am I having to spin these all the way to backtrack?
I can just go through the door?
Really?
Wait, which door?
Wait, this is where I came from.
More back.
Where is the other door?
This door.
Thank you guys.
Okay.
This area is confusing as hell.
Three indentations.
I use the fragment and I use the fragment and I use the fragment!
Now we have an elevator.
Easy.
You can take the red door.
Or you can take the blue door.
Nevermind.
You can take the cutscene.
Oh, the dragons are lowering.
What's going on?
I'm scared.
He plucks the threads that make us dance finger and toe.
We surrender in joy to the lowest of the foul and rank.
We submerge through darkness, rancid filth.
Hour by hour, we move downward, ever closer to heaven.
I don't think you're going down.
You've been going up this whole time!
Now, let the world resonate.
Sloth.
Gluttony.
He pronounces every syllable.
Lust.
Wrath.
Pride.
The bell of chaos that tolls human desires.
After two thousand long years, the once sealed gate to the mnemonic world will open.
Yes!
Destruction!
Carnage and despair!
Let your instincts drive you.
Interrupt this world in fear, as it's bell of name, Teben Negru, strikes the heart of mankind.
Not these things.
They are the worst.
Please, don't make me fight them.
Who's been using their sword against these fuckers?
It was me.
Sparda, once imprisoned...
There'll be...
Guys, I think we were too late.
Nicer!
Well, with that, we have cleared mission 15.
We got 16, 17, 18, 19, 20 left.
Five more missions.
I only got through three missions today.
I'm sorry, guys.
But my computer is acting up.
My camera is acting up.
Every time I just want to update to make things look better and act better for you guys, everything always acts up.
I'm going bonkers from it.
I get a new phone for my camera, it acts up.
I get a new whole ass computer, it acts up.
Like, to give you an idea, my camera for some reason...
It starts auto-looking.
Even if I'm looking straight, it starts making me look like I'm looking to the right.
And I'm like, I don't know why, and so I'm constantly having to fix it.
And it's like drifting.
It feels like it's a Joy-Con drift or something.
It's driving me insane.
Like, I'm looking to the right right now.
See, it slowly moves back.
It's like it's possessed, but not by me.
It's so weird.
Thank you for the super chat, but I can't read it because I can't see.
And because my computer...
Okay, so I'm getting so frustrated about it.
I'm really sorry.
Tech issues are like my number one pet peeve.
Because I feel like it's beyond my control.
But I spend so much money to try and fix it.
And everything always messes up.
Okay, but I had fun with Devil May Cry at least.
At least that was fun.
And we got to fight Virgil again.
And I'm really happy about that because it's always fun to fight him.
Even though I beat him so quickly.
Next is... Next we will beat the game.
I promise.
Next I will... I might start like stream a little bit early in the day and just go until I beat it.
So thank you guys.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm not... I will have to end it on OBS side and then try to find where you guys went.
I was going to ask for a Minto motivation beam, but since you have had...
I'm looking to the right.
Why am I looking to the left?
iPhone, what is wrong with you?
I don't understand.
Why is my camera all messed up?
Sorry.
Since you are having computer issues, I'll give you a PC couldn't fixer beam instead.
Thank you.
I'm looking to the right.
See, it's like confused.
I don't know.
Anyway, sorry.
I don't mean to complain so much.
I'm really sorry.
I'm just getting so frustrated by it all.
OK!
Osu Minto!
Thank you everybody!
See you!
See you next time!
We'll beat Devil May Cry 3 next time!
For sure!
Bye bye!
Thank you for all the motivation!
I'm freaking out.
Everything is...